[Music]
in new rules news new rules new fools
okay submitted by everyone dabbed with a
one-second delay I think I did it right
good one job thank you good one
Netflix film crews are banned from
looking at each other for longer than
five seconds in a hashtag me to
crackdown what what we're having a
conversation so it's like hate what are
you gonna eat today
um I was thinking that we could probably
get some uh that's [ __ ] awkward then
I'll just be hanging out on set like
this standard at titties all day how do
you deal I was like the HR person you're
like um mark stared at me for six
seconds and I don't want to work here
anymore
unless this is taken care of like you're
like [ __ ] who passed this Oh work in HR
their job must be so stressful because
it's already stressful enough as it is
we know someone that works in HR vote
was right she [ __ ] hates her life
yeah she hates her job her life as a h
Harper's yeah yeah it's like until
there's an hour like parameters said to
like this thing when it's like what is
and what like really isn't and like you
know it's like hard right now because
you just have to fire them like you just
have to like what are you supposed to do
shut the [ __ ] up the amount of
complaints you get is it's [ __ ] it's
like someone comes in and like oh you
see that person if you drink all of the
coffee so if you're gonna spend five
dollars an employee on coffee I want a
five dollar tea allowance and then
you're just sitting there going what the
[ __ ] does this have to do with floppy
disks and it's so different poppy did to
do with cd-rom so what you think because
like but what HR people have to deal
with is based on company culture - yeah
because I know a friend who works for
like an animation studio and they make
like sexual jokes 24 [ __ ] seven yeah
and that's okay within that oh you know
I think that's like working for a
[ __ ] porn company and then you're
like you know I feel really
uncomfortable with all the dick jokes
and all the titties around me
ya ever want to see at it ever again as
I work on boobzilla for I wanna watch
that what is it a tall woman with big
boobs just smashing into buildings and
just screaming as she hits
oh she's so instead of guys running away
guys are running toward her if you zoom
in on the nipples is not even nipple
rings a guy just hanging on like look at
you like this that's what it is oh great
take my idea and he's just trying to get
milk off yep are you sure you have like
you know watch this somewhere I'm pretty
sure it's out there I don't like porn
like that we just wrote a movie right
now yeah we're writers comes out like
that damn those are great ideas starting
the rock Oh
starring come on
yeah you thought he was big this is
bigger who's the boobzilla who's a big
TV lady Kato REO Dawson Kate Upton well
sorry Oh Dawson he bit her titties are
you she's not known for big titties yes
she a dude she has like the cities' was
she on Alexander
yeah those titties were already man but
they're not boobzilla boobzilla is like
is like really big loser you're tossing
us indeed son what no but this boobzilla
has to be z where they are what put
alexander rosario Dawson and you'll see
your titties you're fantastic you know
some of the best boobzilla I'm imagining
is like I mean wait wait daddy no that's
a big titties those are big I'm gonna
get suffocated but no no no I want it to
be huge and beautiful but how about
can't how about Kilgore huge daddy's
kata-kata PMC bigger than that
wait I can't
I was picturing a chaos but I was even
picked cheering big one Talent okay
I know just one tip I want a person I
want an actor with emotions
okay I live in the studio argument hire
casting director we gotta be on the same
page can't make this movie if we don't
have the same vision okay
had a reduction because you got can I
see okay well she's got a good nipple
see see that they're really big
I remember oh those are some of the
nicest breasts I've ever seen in my life
good nipple my lips started puckering
when I saw the movie that was the only
good part of Alexander why does it
pucker what does that mean
Mario Dawson had has or had the best
breast on titty experiences on this show
and I appreciate y'all to Rosie oh yeah
very welcome yeah they're not called
funbags for no reason yeah and like you
know if I watch like videos and stuff I
just like hold my thumb over them and
stuff because like you know I'm not into
that yeah yeah yeah
you cover the nipples you just want them
oh just one thumb we're talking about
that's like oh yeah this [ __ ] sexual
harassment yeah so apparently black
mirror right now they're filming
I like black mirror Netflix original
original yeah what if I watch it was
like the UK before and then they like
they were gonna cancel and they were
like no no no no no this is modern-day
Twilight Zone bring it back [ __ ]
because you know there's projects that
are like the fully film ready then they
sell it and that's a Netflix original
yep but then there's Netflix original
original original that day shop so I
didn't know if it was oh it's not in the
beginning they didn't it okay so now
it's our original original
yeah so yeah they're yeah no no that's
what the quality is so different all
across the board
mm-hmm
yeah and so uh during their filming they
had this like sort of seminar thing yeah
and so does your team huddle you can't
look at each other for more than five
seconds look at you guys
well there's a lot of room that's sad
because everybody is who's single [ __ ]
in the workplace so let me tell you the
rules so how he's supposed to do that
then she's gonna tell you the rule he
doesn't know the article no ball guys
how do you [ __ ] in the workplace if you
can't look oh sorry I meant [ __ ] with
your coworkers you [ __ ] out of the
workplace not at work that's what I mean
like how do you [ __ ] your coworkers then
oh you know supposed to do that people
do all the time no that's how you build
a really good bond
you've never [ __ ] your coworker you're
liar no it's a Spartan way we've all
[ __ ] our coworkers yeah I mean
different yeah you [ __ ] it we were
together first and then we be God's law
workers couple of my co-workers and my
other jobs working up you lazy [ __ ] all
right saw the rules yeah one of your
co-workers were all [ __ ] ugly that's
what the girl that [ __ ] that you
[ __ ] is probably saying all my but I
saw one alright so the first rule that
they've listed here is don't look at
anyone for longer than five seconds
let's dump out stop don't do that
[Laughter]
don't give lingering hugs or touch
anyone for a delay a fiery enough time I
like hugs I'm a hugger
don't flirt yeah impossible don't ask
out a colleague more than once if they
have said no steer clear of a colleague
once they have said they are not
interested in you don't ask for a
colleagues phone number and report a
colleague who has given anyone unwanted
attention prevails
that's so rapey I can't hug people not
if you got Netflix lingering hugs you're
telling me I can't hug someone and then
walk down their back what and then
moonwalk backwards with my fingers do
you want to go on a date with me this
man has literally tackled me armed
barred me and then tickle my balls do
you walk today and I've had my head in
between her breasts and I said it's so
nice to see you
yeah but you know what all of that [ __ ]
isn't isn't creepy though what what I
think some people deal with it you know
with these [ __ ] thirsty creepy dudes
that's the weird [ __ ] right giving some
chicks with dudes like there's just like
yo I don't want to [ __ ] you like get
away from you lady yeah I'm seeing that
I've seen girls like a strong woman
no like just the guy's just trying to be
nice but like he just doesn't want to be
like a total prick so he's a little bit
more on the passive side yeah and then
I've seen girls just sit on it like sit
on their lap yeah like bro come on like
right the workplace or whatever oh that
must be nice not if it's a morning yeah
bits unwanted it's it's like it's gross
yeah well I wasn't think anyone want it
you can't see me talking about a one
yeah it's weird well because it's like
when we were at VidCon we had a fan come
up and kiss one of our cast mates like
she just like walking through my
straight up kiss out like on a lip yeah
like it was like right here like she was
trying to get it but we were like ma'am
we just all like took pictures but it
kissed her back you made her feel
uncomfortable do it it was like man
you know how you uh she started it you
started it
it was kiss defense oh it was like a
kiss jab and you went with us kiss hook
we give each other kisses say hello
don't stick my tongue out like you drag
it drag it along to face yeah he's like
a boa right now or parts like this it
goes havoc you see every max can do it
man what am i god what have I done you
like come here it's your culture right
[ __ ] say what's up I know he's [ __ ]
crazy
coworker and he would always flirt with
me and then one time he gave me a kiss
and it was like [ __ ] hello Chloe
hello like 14 15
why was he kissing you for hating a lot
of things but he kissed me so I think
he'd kissed the corner of my mouth was a
25 no I mean I was 15 he was like 26 or
something oh is this at the restaurant
what I used to work in Mexico if you're
26 and you find a 15 year old tractive
yeah but it's a Mexico oh no I mean girl
he has a point
yep it's the dawn Ken perv they don't
they don't care yeah it seems like look
I mean not all every single Mexican man
obviously but when you see a girl says
like Senora junior high just turns you
on
so you hunt you in your head
good decent Mexican man out there just
talking about that
what's the huh you let it all when you
find him and they're just they're
mexican-american guys no I'm sorry about
the Mexico Mexicans
I don't know I just but I don't know I
just heard throughout my life from like
guys that like girls they don't care
what age they just if she got body parts
they're like 15 is the maximum ya know
they just a maximum they're just [ __ ]
every bigot anything
[Music]